>>> KNOCK KNOCK.
>> SIMU, WHAT'S UP, MY FELLOW
YELLOW FELLOW?
>> WHAT?
>> NOTHING
I'M JUST NERVOUS
I THINK, I MEAN, THIS HAS NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE, RIGHT
ASIAN MALE HOST.
ASIAN MALE CAST MEMBER
>> I KNOW.
IT'S LIKE WE'RE THE SPIDER-MAN
MEME
>> YEAH.
EXCEPT, YOU HAVE ABS
AND I HAVE -- IBS.
>> IBS
>> I-B-S
ANYWAY, CONGRATS, MAN.
I MEAN, FIRST ASIAN MARVEL LEAD,
THAT'S HUGE.
>> OH, THANK YOU
I ALMOST CAN'T WRAP MY AHEAD
AROUND IT.
I MEAN, YOU GET IT, RIGHT?
LIKE, FIRST FULLY ASIAN CAST
MEMBER ON SNL?
AMAZING.
>> OH, YEAH.
THANKS
I JUST THINK IT'S WEIRD THAT
PEOPLE KEEP TRACK OF THIS STUFF,
THOUGH
>> AH, YEAH.
TOTALLY.
I MEAN, I JUST GOT THIS.
FIRST ASIAN MAN TO MOVE FROM
CANADA TO AMERICA.
>> I HAVE ONE THAT SAYS BOWEN.
>> OH, NICE.
YEAH, I JUST FORGET TO TAKE MINE
OFF.
>> HEY, BOWEN, I HAVE AN AWARD
FOR YOU.
YOU ARE THE FIRST GAY ASIAN CAST
MEMBER TO MISPRONOUNCE BOUTIQUE.
>> IS IT NOT BOUTIQUEA
>> NO.
>> AW, MAN, THAT'S SO HISTORIC
>> AND SIMU, YOU WERE JUST NAMED
THE FIRST ASIAN MAN TO DEAD PAN
ON SPLASH MOUNTAIN
>> WOW, CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANKS.
>> BUT SERIOUSLY, "SHANG-CHI"
WAS SO GOOD.
>> THANK YOU
YEAH, I GUESS THEY'RE SAYING I'M
THE FIRST ASIAN MAN TO BLOW UP A
DRAGON FROM THE INSIDE
>> I GOT THE SAME ONE TOO BUT IT
MEANS SOMETHING ELSE
>> ANYWAY, DON'T YOU THINK IT'S
KIND OF -- KIND OF RIDICULOUS.
>> TOTALLY
LIKE, THE STATE OF MICHIGAN GAVE
ME "THE GOOD JOB PARENTHESES
ASIAN" AWARD, I DO NOT CARE.
♪
>> TO EVERY ASIAN ON THE PLANET,
I DID THIS FOR YOU
>> I KNOW.
FIRST ASIAN MAN TO BEAT
"STARCRAFT 2."
I DIDN'T EVEN GO TO THE
CEREMONY
♪
>> WHOO!
THERE'S JUST NO TRUE WAY TO SAY
THIS
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> HEY, MR. ASIAN PANERA, THESE
ARE FOR YOU.
>> OH, MY GOD, FOR ME.
>> WHAT IS MR. ASIAN PANERA?
>> OH, I GUESS I WAS THE FIRST
ASIAN TO YOU-PICK-TWO A PANERA
OR SOMETHING
>> I DID IT.
I DID IT
I PICKED TWO
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S ALMOST
EMBARRASSING
LIKE I DIDN'T EVEN TELL ANYONE
ABOUT BEING ONE OF PEOPLE'S
SEXIEST MEN ALIVE.
>> MOM, I'M HOT.
>> WEREN'T YOU THE FIRST OPENLY
BOTTOM GUY ON THAT LIST?
>> I'M NOT OPEN ABOUT THAT
WHO TOLD YOU THAT?
>> SORRY, I JUST GUESSED
>> OH, NICE.
GOOD JOB
>> HEY, I HAVE ANOTHER AWARD FOR
FIRST ASIAN MAN TO DO A CHER
IMPRESSION ON NBC, BUT IT
DOESN'T SAY WHO IT'S FOR
♪ IF I COULD TURN BACK TIME
>> SIMU WINS
>> YES
>> CONGRATULATIONS
BUT JUST REMEMBER, SIMU.
WHATEVER FIRST THING YOU DO,
I'LL ALWAYS BE GAY
♪